- Nicki Minaj is opening tonight.
Love Nicki, right?
- It's gonna be great.
It's gonna be great.
- You've heard "Truffle Butter", right?
- Well, yeah. (laughing)
- So you know what
truffle butter is, right?
- I know exactly what it is.
- Truffle butter?
- Yeah, you know what it is?
- I don't think I do.
- You have a really
mischievous look right now.
- I've looked it up and sorry I did;
I was like"Oh-oh."
- Oh, my God! We were just
talking about this in the car.
- My brother told me the definition.
My brother is 15.
- How does he know this?
- [Guy in Plaid] Whoa!
- You know, kids these days.
- We brought some truffle
butter to the Carpet today
for everyone to try.
We figured snacks might be in order.
- You brought your own truffle butter?
- Yeah.
- [Guy in Plaid] Yeah.
- Really?
- [Guy in Light Blue] Yes.
Do you want to try some?
- Well, I don't know, I might get it
all in my teeth or whatnot.
- Do you want white or
black truffle butter?
- Well, Rebecca Black should
have black truffle butter.
- Actually, yeah, that's
not even a question.
Give it a whiff?
- Oh, that's bad!
- It smells excellent.
(T-Pain gagging)
- Just a little whiff.
- Is this gonna make my breath smell bad?
- Oh, it'll ruin you for the
rest of the night, Rebecca.
- Okay, I'm a little nervous;
I'm a little excited.
- I want you to taste
it; I want you to tell me
what it makes you think about.
- A little garlic, a little creamy,
nice and dreamy.
- It's really good!
- Potent.
- If I licked a butt crack...
- Oh, God!
- That's probably what
it would taste like.
- Wow!
- Is there a good way of that?
- Yeah, it's 2015, (mumbling)
- I'm not a fan.
- You're not a fan?
- Not a fan.
- I'm not gonna lie.
- You don't like our truffle butter?
- I'm pretty disappointed
in Buzz Feed right now.
- I'm sorry.
- I'll dip it and feed it to you.
Stick out that tongue.
Oh, my God! I can't believe we're in love.
Get him a lot of that truffle.
- I feel bad.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah! Oh yeah!
- So you like both of our truffle butters?
- I do.
- Great to hear.
- But what is truffle butter really,
'cause now you guys are
making me seem dirty?
- Oh, I was talking about the porn
version of truffle butter.
- What are you talking about?
Obviously, this is what
Nicki Minaj is singing about,
the delicate treat of truffle butter.
- It's a high-class delicacy.
- Absolutely, not.